じゃ実際に着てた反論を僕が今から呼んで
いくのでそれに対して校長が答えていただ
くっていう形で動画を進めたいと思います
[音楽]
はいトカヨットスクールでは体罰を使う
けど体罰を使わずに子供を説得することが
できたら体罰なんて必要ないこれについて
はどう思います
からやりゃいいじゃんどうしてみんな
おかしいの体罰受けてない子がみんな
おかしになってくじゃんで人生無駄にする
やろ結局うんあそこで言うこと聞いときゃ
別に無駄にならずにちゃんとした人生を
遅れたのにというこういう霊知っとる光る
より褒めろこれが正しいんだと言い続けた
バカマスコミはその結果全く叱られずに
幼児期から少年期まで過ごすやつが出てき
たいどういう風になるか知っとるそういう
連中が罪の意識ができない罪の意識ができ
ないと平気で悪いことやる責任感ができ
ないだから社会性が作れない罪の意識が
ないと社会性ができない
よ例えばあれなんかそうやね大量殺人を
やっちまう琢磨琢磨の言分聞いたことある
ないよねそこがいかんのやないか泥棒にも
3部のりっていうやろ彼にもなんか理由が
あるはずない彼の手紙やったかなあれを
読むとなぜ自分はこんな風になっちまうん
やろうと悪いことばっかりしちまうで悩ん
どるんやでその結果自分は生きててはいか
んのだという結論に達するんで生きてては
いかんけども自分で自分を殺す自殺する
だけの度胸がないだったら死刑なろうと
いうこういう考えの多いよねこの頃そう
いう琢磨みたいな人を言葉でちゃんと説得
するべきっていう意見がたくさんあったん
ですけどできるわけないじゃん罪の意識が
ないんやから責任感がないああいうね言葉
で分からせろという連中は実際にそういう
人間にあったことない努力して言葉で
分からせたこともない自分のできんことと
人に押し付けるなともっとひどいのはね
タレントや女のタレントでね子供が2歳
だっていうんや自分は2歳の子供にだって
言って聞かせる決して叱らんて言っとるん
や2歳の子供がわかんの叱ったら分かる
やろ言って聞かして分かるのか体罰とかは
その場では行動を直すんだけどその体罰が
なくなったら結局何も変わらない
逆言えば分かるというあれはそば限りだ
体罰はずっと聞くよあのさっき話てろ俺が
聞いとるのん小さい頃やられた体罰が実際
にやったこともない人が言うんじゃない
なんて言っとるんやリベラルという哲学で
言っとるんや哲学なんか役に立つもんか
個人的に思ったのがどヨットスクールに
来る子供たちがどういう人なのかっていう
のが世間があんま分かってなくて普通の
言っても言うこと聞くような子たちがが来
てるのにわざわざ殴ったりしてるっていう
風な反論がたくさんあったんですねなので
トカヤットスクールに来る子供達てどう
いう人たちなのかっていうのをちょっと
伺ってもいいですかうちは高いから
けしからんて言われとるんやその高い金を
払ってまで子供をやるんやでどんなことか
想像がつくじゃんもう手に負えんてことな
言ってわかりゃ手に負えるんや言っても
分からんから手に終えんのやそういう子供
が来るんじゃ
ないお前も体罰を受けろていうのがさん
ありましたもう受けただからそれを次のや
にやってやっとるんやないか自分が体罰
受けたそれは良かっただから自分も次のや
にやってやらんといかんそう思っとるわけ
よだから体罰も受けたことがない効果も
知らないやが体罰できるわけないじゃん
経験のないやつが物を言うからいかんのや
だからさっき言った地行合一知ってるって
いうことはできるということだったらお前
は子供を説得して投稿拒否直してみでき
たらよやってみろ俺はその子のためになる
ぞできるもんなら投拒否のこともなんか
散々説得されとるわけやろでも全然何にも
起こらんじゃん帰ってマイナスになっ
ちゃうやろいこじになっちまったり日が
ちまったり自分はダメだなんて思い込ん
じまったりそうなるわね体罰を受けること
で立ち直れなくなってしまう子供もいるん
じゃないかって
いうそんなものはその前が悪いんだ前に
そういうことをやられとれば強くなっとれ
ばということ体罰なんかありがたいと思う
んだそれがそれを一発受けたがために
立ち直れんて言うんなら弱すぎるんよ最初
にもっと強くしとかないか幼時期に散々
甘やかしといてで弱いと言って文句は言え
んやろだからまず幼児期から叱るの
しっかり叱る体罰のしっかりするで子供を
強くしておこ強いことが大事や今そうやっ
て言ってくるのは弱いやつばっかりやろ
自分がやられたら怖いとかマスコミなんか
そうよねしっかりしろよ言って特に男が
そんなこと言ってはいかんそれは女の言う
ことや次に結構多かったのが昭和の教育論
今は令和だから時代に合ってい
ない古いっていうね古いイコール悪い
新しいイコール良い証明できるのそんな
こと新しいのはまだやってないんだから
いいか悪いかわからんじゃん古いのはもう
ちゃんと経験済み実施済みだからいいもの
が多いんだそれが正しいからいつまでも
使われて古くなったんだ間違ったことは
古くならんやろすぐ捨てられるんだからだ
から古い結構なことやそれを革命が正しい
というバカともひっくり返すのがええんだ
というこれ左翼しそうって言うんやろう
けど間違ってるに決まってるじゃん正しい
ものをひっくり返す間違いになる古いもの
は正しいんだ大体昔の人よりお前は頭が
悪いしより褒めて伸ばせていうのも新しい
教育論なんですか
ね褒めて伸ばせ褒めたら伸びないそれと
体罰がけしからんとかなそういう風になっ
ていくんやいつまで褒めるんだ大人になっ
ても褒めるのか大体褒めてばっかりおっ
たら大人になれんやろ叱られたら大人に
なってくやろ今がいかんて言っとるんだ
からもっと伸びろて言っとるわけやねだ
から褒めて伸びろは嘘都合がええから信じ
とるだけであって光るより褒める方が楽
やろ叱るのは難しい褒めるのは簡単やお
ベンチャ言っときゃええんや叱れない人が
自分を弁護するために褒めて伸ばせと言っ
とるわけ褒めたら伸びないこれに関連して
ま僕ら20代なんですけど同世代が会社を
すぐに辞めちゃうとかあと上司に怒られ
たらパワハっていうとかそういう若者が
忍耐力がないいっていうのが結構問題に
なってるんですけどこれについては何が
原因だと考えですか
褒めてのばが原因やそうなっちゃうんよ
褒められてばっかり寄ってみ自分が偉いと
思うやろだから会社の上司なんか偉くない
んだ自分は偉いけど上の方が偉くないだっ
たら叱るのはけしらんのよお前らごきが
なぜ俺を叱るんだということになっちまう
本当のことでもんねこんな会社やめて
やろうということになる会社喜ぶわな早く
やめてくれそういうのがうちに来とったで
大学にストレートで入ってストレートで
卒業してきて会社に入ったけど何の仕事も
できないしょうがないから現場にやった
工場の中にこういう製品を運ぶ道ができ
とるんや舗装されたその真ん中に釣ったて
いうんよ仕事もせずにそしたらトロッコを
してきた現場の人がどけつったんや邪魔や
からそのバカお前今俺のことをボケと言っ
ただろうこんな会社やめてやろつってそう
したら上司がスんできて本当だね本当だね
言ってみんなやめてもらいたいんだでうち
に来と上司が褒めて伸ばすことはダメなん
ですか褒めて伸ばしたらねうまく盗撮が
取れんようになるよ信頼されるあるいは
尊敬される尊敬されると全てうまくいくん
やその上司の元でねどうしたら尊敬される
ようになるのちゃんと
話し合う2つの要素があるんだ1つは罰が
公平なこと叱るのもちゃんと叱り方が
しっかりしとる偉い人でも偉くない人でも
叱る時は正しく叱るもう1つ守る力がある
ことや罰が公平なことというのは進歩させ
てやろうとしとるわけでもう1つは本人を
守ってやろうとしとるわけその2つがあっ
たらば尊敬されるんや尊敬されたらその
偉い人のいうことはよう聞くんだ褒めて
ばっかりおる人馬鹿にされるんや俺より
ダメだから俺を褒めとるんだろういうこと
になるから誰が言うこと聞くそれが社会や
で自分に都合よく夢みたいなことを考え
とったらあ
[音楽]
かM